sa bouche
jean paul ii venu dans ce paradis comme
beaucoup aujourd'hui
liliane a perdu son idole ses souvenirs
c'est justement ce qui lui restera de
celui qui l'a accompagné depuis ses 13
ans j'avais une amie qui avait deux ans
de plus que moi donc c'était la grande
voile à petit puis un jour elle me dit
il ya johnny hallyday qui sort à 1,10 et
nous la partie acheter ce fameux disque
qui est sorti en mars 1960
j'ai pratiquement tous ses disques
toujours tous les albums mais en fin de
compte on a de la peine on a de la peine
et puis alors comme tu écoutes les
témoignages de tout le monde est obligé
d'avoir une grande peine s'est il fait
partie de ma vie depuis l'âge que j'ai
13 ans et j'en ai de 70 à une vie
rythmée par les sorties d'albums et les
concerts fans dévoués liliane a suivi
son johnny partout même à l'autre bout
de l'atlantique monde à ce qu'une
oubliable celle de jeff guess en 1985
mme hervé de las vegas mes parents me
faire ça pour mes 50 ans est un vrai
beau le départ à l'aéroport des petits
johnny partout des dans l'avion dans
l'avion tout ce qu'on a eues mais je
pourrais le parti mille fois à las vegas
je n'aurais jamais un voyage comme ça et
on est des femmes
c'était formidable pour se rappeler ces
bons moments des objets à l'effigié de
son icône des dédicaces et des photos
pour l'entourer dernière acquisition en
date de son club
les calendriers 2018 malheureusement que
johnny ne verra pas le calendrier du fan
club de nîmes et alès ayant nahd
ou alors ils ont fait d'eux une
collection qui continuera de s'agrandir
malgré la perte et la tristesse ne
restera que les saisies mais reste dans
toutes ses chansons